توصف فاجنر بانها شركه عسكريه خاصه
وياراها اخرون اقرب ما تكون الى مجموعه
روسيه عسكريه شبه رسميه فهي وحده تتمتع
وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز بالاستقلاليه
وتتبع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه يعتقد ان
مؤسسها هو لمتر اوتكين ضابط سابق في القوه
الخاصه وحملت اسمه السري فاجنر لكنها الان
مملوكه لرجل الاعمال
ويعرف باسم طباخ بوتين لاداره شركه
كونكورد المنظمه لحفظه الاستقبال
بالكريملاند وتضم مزيجا من مقاتلنا يقدمون
خدماتهم مقابل المال بدات العمل لاول مره
مع ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم في عام 2014
ونفذتها هجمات في شرق اوكرانيا يقول
مسؤولون بريطانيون ان عدد مقاتل ارتفع من
نحو الفا الى ما يقرب من 20,000 مقاتل في
اوكرانيا اين نحو عشره في المئام الاجمال
القوات الروسيه على الارض
افتتح بريكوجين اول مقر لفاكنر في مدينه
سان بطرسبورغ الروسيه وقال في بيانه مهمته
مركز فاجنر هي توفير بيئه مريحه لتوليد
افكار جديده بغيه تحسين القدره الدفاعيه
لروسيا
وتحسين القدره دفاعيه لروسيا لا يمكنه
اخفاء حقيقه الاتهامات لفاكنر لارسال
مسلحيها الى عده دول في امريكا اللاتينيه
وافريقيا وتنفيذ ما توصف بالعمليه القذره
في مناطق النزاعات المختلفه ففي سوريا
انتشرت فاجنر لدعم النظام السوري منذ 2016
خصوصا حول حقول النفط في دير الزور وخطفت
الاضواء اكثر بعد مقتل عدد من افرادها في
غاره امريكيه عام 2018
وتنشط المجموعه في ليبيا منذ 2016 وتدعم
القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خلف حفتر
وكشف تقرير للامم المتحده وجود اكثر من
1,000 من عناصرها لكن تقرر اخرى تقدرهم
بالالاف
كما تنتشر ميليشيا فاغنر في جمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى لحراسه مناجم الذهب
والالماس وتشير تقارير الى وجود الله في
مدغشقر وموزمبيق والسودان وكان اخر انتشار
لها في مالي بعد انسحاب القوه الفرنسيه من
هناك